is there some sense Can you steal me on
the case that this class difference is
over exaggerated
that
there's a difference
but it's not the difference of the
abuser and the abused
it's more of a difference of
uh people that were successful and
people that were less successful so I'll
play Devil's Advocate which is a that
maybe
one could argue that it's purest
earliest stage capitalism was based on a
Stark
difference but then since then two
things have happened one a bunch of
socialists and workers have organized to
guarantee certain rights for Working
Class People certain protections so then
our system now there are certain safety
nets Less in the U.S than in other
countries but in a lot of countries are
pretty extensive safety nets even like
40-hour work week minimum wage safety
regulations all that kind of stuff yeah
and all those things are
in my mind doses of socialism within
capitalism because what you're doing is
you are taking the autonomy of
capitalists to do whatever they want
with the people contracted to them
and the only thing stopping them is you
know them potentially being able to go
to another employer but even then it's
kind of a potentially a race to the
bottom if you know you can't get more
than uh two dollars an hour from any
employer in your in your Market
you're going to have to you know live
with it so one factor is we have built
in those Productions so we've taken
enough socialism into capitalism that
you could say that at a certain point
maybe it makes a qualitative difference
and not just a quantitative difference
in people's lives the other thing is
over time we've gotten wealthier and
more productive as a society
so maybe at some point the quantitative
difference of just more and more wealth
means that even if in the abstract the
division between a worker and a
capitalist is real if that worker is
earning you know a quarter million
dollars a year and has a good life and
only has to clock in 35 hours a week 30
hours a week
and has you know four weeks of vacation
then like isn't it just like an abstract
or philosophical
um difference so I think you could level
those two arguments what I would say is
that one
um
a lot of these rights that we have
fought for are constantly being eroded
and they're under attacked in part
because the economic power the
capitalists have bleeds into our
political democracy as well there's
constant lobbying for all sorts of labor
market deregulations and um and so on
um I fundamentally believe
that if tomorrow all those regulations
went away capitalists would fight to pay
people as little as possible and we'll
be back in 19th century capitalism and
not because they're bad people because
if I'm running a firm and all of a
sudden my competition is paying is is
able to find a labor pool and is paying
people less than me I'm going to be
undercut because they'll be able to take
some of that extra savings and invest
into new technology or whatever else and
they'll gobble up my market share before
long
um and then also beyond that I do think
there's a normative question here which
is
now do we believe that ordinary people
have a capacity
to be able to make certain decisions
about their work do we believe they know
more about their work than their bosses
um now I don't think that's not true at
every level but I think there's no doubt
that in workplaces workers know how to
productively do their tasks in ways that
their manager might not know I think
we've all been in workplaces where we've
had managers who kind of don't know what
you do or what what whatever else
um and I think that collectively if
incentivized we could uh have them one
instead of hoarding or that information
um since they're getting a stake in in
production and and so on they'd be able
to more freely share it and be able to
reshape how their day-to-day work
happens
and also with with elect demanders you
kind of take it up the the chain I think
you would have perfectly efficient
market-based firms
um that that could exist without
capitalists so there's a I mean there's
a lot of uh things to say
maybe within just very very low level
question of if the workers are running
the show
there's a brutal truth to the fact that
some people are better and the workers
know this
is the Steve Jobs a players you want to
have all the a players in the room
because one B player can poison the pool
because then everybody gets demotivated
by like uh
by the nature of that
lack of excellence and competence this
is just to take sort of a crude Devil's
Advocate perspective
are the workers going to be able to
remove the incompetent from the pool
in the in the name in the goal of
towards the mission of succeeding as a
collective so I think that any
successful model of socialism that
involves the market you need two things
one is at the micro level you need the
ability to uh fire people and for them
to exit firms which might be a slower
process in uh Cooperative based firms
than it is in a capitalist firm without
a union but it would be probably akin to
the process that would happen in a
capitalist firm of which there are many
with unions
um so you need that and then at the
macro level you need firm failure you
need to avoid a dilemma that happened in
Soviet style economies which was soft
budget you know constraints and
um firms basically not being allowed to
fail because the government was
committed to Full Employment the firms
employed people so even inefficient
firms were at the end of the day they
knew they were going to be propped up by
the government and they would be given
all the resources they would need no
matter how efficient inefficiently they
were using those resources to maintain
employment so I think you need you need
both do you worry about this idea of
firing people
man I'm uncomfortable with the idea I
hate it but I also know it's extremely
necessary
so is there something about a collective
a socialist system that makes firing you
said it might be slower might it become
extremely slow too much friction isn't
there a tension between respecting the
rights of a human being and saying like
you need to step up uh maybe sort of
deposit the carrot like you you really
like to really encourage fellow workers
know when they're there's a person
that's not pulling their side of the do
doing as great of a job as they could be
like they
but isn't the person that's not doing a
great of a job going to start to
manipulate the system that slows the
firing in their self-interest
well I think there would be certain so
maybe another way to to put it is think
about like if you're a partner at a law
firm right
um I don't really know how law firms
work so I probably shouldn't use this
analogy but but correct me if I'm wrong
but let's say you're a partner you kind
of have equity in your Law Firm or
something beyond your billable hours and
let's say you're um going to be fired
from your Law Firm or they're laying off
people or whatever else they'll they
could just get rid of you but they would
also have to figure out how to kind of
buy you out too after a certain point so
I think that like in a in a Cooperative
firm you'd probably have a system where
you after a certain point of working
productively you probably have a period
where you can get fired really quickly
uh no matter what but once you do a job
security kicks in you would be able to
um you know it would be a process it
would probably be like you know a day or
two process to figure it out or maybe
they would have a progressive discipline
process which is first you have to get
at a verbal feedback and then maybe a
written performance review then you
could be fired I mean that's how it
works in a lot of workplaces with either
unions or with just basic job security
um in most countries that's how it works
because there's not at will employment
in most countries so I think that
that the real tension is
if you fire someone if you're condemning
them to destitution then morally you you
really feel something there as you
should as a human being concerned about
other other people but in a social
system or even basic Social Democratic
system there would be mechanisms to take
care of that person so one if a firm is
failing for any reason they're getting
out compete or whatever whatever else
those workers would then land in the
hands just for a little bit of the state
right and there could be active labor
market policies to retrain people to go
into expanding sectors or your sector is
now obsolete but here you have these
skills you're going to be trained and
and hear some resources to kind of help
you along your training and then there's
a bunch of firms hiring so go on your
way and then also just with an expanded
welfare state being destitute in certain
countries being unemployed in certain
countries is easier than in other
countries or situations so you know you
still can fall back on on that mechanism
and also in my vision of of
um of Market socialism a democratic
socialism uh there would be an expanded
State sector
um not not anything you can imagine but
the way in which there's more of a state
sector in countries like Norway or
Denmark than there is in the US so there
would be you know various forms of state
employment and whatever whatever else
um so I mean I think that the real
question is should being bad at your job
or getting fired for any reason or
getting laid off should that be a cause
to have you you know totally lose your
shirt or maybe should you just have to
rebound maybe you have less money for
consumption or whatever else and you'll
be on your way onto bigger and better
things you know in a in a few months so
a strong social net
in many ways make it uh more efficient
to fire people who are not good at their
job because then they won't be
um that won't actually significantly
damage their quality of life and they
have a chance to find a job at which
they can flourish sure right